so you'll remember there's been this
long-running inquiry following on from
the Sue gray report into partygate and
what happened in Downing street during
the pandemic we have a committee of MPS
who've been looking at whether Boris
Johnson misled Parliament about it when
he was telling Parliament what he knew
when MPS were asking questions about it
now we haven't heard very much on this
inquiry over the last few months because
we know they were given a cache of
documents and pictures from people who
worked in Downing Street and by the
government which they were looking
through we have now just learned two
things the first is that Boris Johnson
will be giving evidence to them he will
be questioned by the MPS on that
committee next week he's been invited to
go there and he must take up that
invitation we've also been has seen
published a 24-page report by that
committee including some pictures which
look at first glance to me to be
different from the pictures we have seen
previously of gatherings in Downing
Street if you can see them on the screen
there they um they do show Boris Johnson
and other people standing round the
cabinet table but there seemed to be a
few more people there than we saw in the
pictures that we have that were
published previously so there's 24 pages
of things that that committee wants to
ask Boris Johnson about next week and we
are just digesting all the information
in that report